[Music]
oh God okay I'm gonna give you a [ __ ]
Sophie's Choice bro
stop
stutter and John
or [ __ ] haters Opie
um
let's do Opie let's save stutter and
John for later you know nightwave needs
prep I got you uh yeah
she said Opie's a little more draining
and all right rather get this over with
all right
let me guess he doesn't even think about
these guys okay
okay
I keep bringing him up merch cannot
doesn't know this video I just he just
let's see oh no but I know okay so so
this is a one minute and four second
video
how many times do you think he's let's
play the game it's gonna be fun how many
times he's gonna say he doesn't care
how many times you're gonna think it's
gonna go he's over it and how many times
he's gonna say haters
one minute and four second video this is
fun with Opie
um he's gonna say haters twice he's
gonna say he's over it twice maybe maybe
three times all right let's see
but this is how it works in life if you
don't respect something okay I'm sorry
did he just die and this is a yearbook
Memorial what is this filter what is
this he looks like a black guy that's
airbrushed on a t-shirt
I will remember you oh my God it looks
like he's on he looks like he should be
on a t-shirt that says R.I.P unk
yeah you're right it's more of a black
thing it's it's not it's it's not this
is the song that it would be
yeah exactly and it would be in Romans
exactly
that's the black funeral song Boyz II
Men it's hard to say goodbye and it's a
picture of them drinking Hennessy out of
red Solo cups like it's never even a
good picture
it's always them at like a car show in a
7-Eleven parking lot pouring Hennessy
into red cops oh [ __ ] love black
funerals like not because black people
die but
the context Virgie
out of context version
well not because black people die though
[ __ ] virgin
base
oh [ __ ] me I was playing power levels a
little bit bud
Jesus Madonna's Paul would hope he
finally dies I'm going to airbrush this
on an old Impala and tell black people
it's it's be a wall
but this is how it works in life if you
don't respect somebody and they're
talking about you why would you care
bleeping it out to get that monetization
don't want that bad boy on yellow huh
what the [ __ ] I don't give two craps
that counts as I don't care that counts
as and I don't care okay I don't uh here
I'll put it on the big that's one and a
half so far
I don't give two craps that's two you
said three right
I don't have respect for either one of
those guys so why would I care because
you made a clip about it
if you don't respect someone I don't why
would you care what they have to say
is that how you felt every time there
was a comedian in there and everyone was
riffing
they didn't respect you they didn't care
what you had to say except if it was a
[ __ ] uh Steven Singer commercial or
whatever it was
tell you the truth
you were lying previously
like you were to management about how
much you love the employees here here's
some here's uh here's some truth
finally we're gonna get we're gonna dig
deep into Opie we're gonna he's gonna
hear something he hasn't said before
what can it be
Brothers
did anybody see brother wheeze coming up
I didn't okay I didn't have him on the
car no
was she talking me and saying some
really god-awful things about me
and uh and the person I was right I
would be incredibly brother wheeze only
matters to you brother wheeze only
matters to you brother wheeze only
matters to you
nobody cares about your F list radio
Idol I don't know man I care about him
in Rochester
holy [ __ ]
Christ
sorry that brother wheeze was only
famous at Danbury Trasher games or
whatever but like what the [ __ ] dude
incredibly bumped incredibly bumped
but this is how it works in life if you
don't respect somebody and they're
talking about you why would you care
there's no reason to care at that point
you made an entire monetized video about
it Opie
because he wants people to know he
doesn't care he doesn't care
the only thing that stupid haters the
only thing that he clips
are drama stuff that that's that's the
only thing
the real reason Anthony was fired a
haircut today that's good though thank
you yeah yeah it looks good wait August
3rd 20 a haircut today that's good
though thank you yeah it looks good this
is older episode subscribe to Opie Radio
what is I don't understand what's this
from
August 3rd what is this
hanging in there and it's just audio my
my hair cutter he's got like bronchitis
okay I don't care I'll be sorry about
that
and I could easily
pop back into the spotlight
he can guys they're cramering for Opie
every time I hear it all I hear oh
that's all I hear from people when is
Opie coming back
and then when you know if he's not on
screen people should be talking about
Opie like where is Opie
what
I hope he had to go back to this planet
he really is the poochievement he really
is oh he even dresses like him kind of
if the opportunity Roger right the
backwards Patty what's up dudes Opie why
are you playing with these filters what
the [ __ ] is going on I don't know what
he's doing man
some experimental Levant guard [ __ ]
or whatever [ __ ] filter Apple Movie
Maker has
boom Opie are you retired no he meant to
say [ __ ]
I was gonna say a story I was using
speech to text yeah I apologize
the next one is just star [ __ ]
I'm not necessarily [ __ ] I am on the
Spectrum oh you're not retired so you're
unemployed tired
I make a little living doing this so I'm
still doing it on a much there's I'm
looking at your numbers you're not
making a living
foreign
we're making more money than you from
our show and we're not even happy hey yo
we're making more money on this episode
and we're not even monetized yeah
lower level
I don't think you could ever really
retire somebody is Dana just reminded us
regarding the the Aries Spears thing
just a reminder The Rock Plato pedophile
robot sketch on SNL
so
but I did because I never had a real job
Opie it is very apparent that you've
never had a real job okay you do not
comport yourself as a man who's ever had
a real job
and I could easily
pop back into the spotlight do it do it
you [ __ ] Mark
do it I'll be there I'll plug your
[ __ ] first show
we'll be there with bells on I will
simulcast it
and make fun of it but still
if the opportunity is right
I did have an opportunity
um cool hey
Opie you want to be our board up I bet
you we pay better than your YouTube
career
I'm trying to remember how long ago this
was at least a month ago
legit company
watches this live stream on a regular
basis they like what I do
you know they know the legit company
watches his live stream they like what
he do is this Westwood One all over
again Marsh is this going to be another
Westwood one situation he's gonna get
another deal yeah big deal where he
films podcasts of him recording
silverware at Waffle Houses around the
city oh you're gonna have to dust off
charades small Christy Stefano Jesus
here I could point and [ __ ] you
definitely have to dust off that Cuban
Chef there's filler but well dig up
first I guess but with the podcast I
just added all the filler out and I'm
making it to a spoken a smoking podcast
smoking
remember the smoking remember the mask
smoking
I just kept doing it first off if you're
if we were any Mask movie it would
either be the [ __ ] one or son of
thee so I mean
and their deal is they want to get me
Eric Schultz right that was Eric Schultz
who played the [ __ ] in the the other man
the mask with the [ __ ] face guy back
in a studio doing my thing and I'm like
I don't want to do that
and then I was like if you could figure
out something
to maybe pump this up
and then I also did tell him to be
completely truthful I'm like I
not sure if I want to do somebody said
come on dude almost 2K people are
watching this dumb [ __ ] excuse me you're
not taking in the rumble numbers and the
Odyssey numbers well over 2 000 people
are watching this dumb [ __ ] yeah thanks
this dumb [ __ ] is actually being watched
by almost 3 000 people yeah so oh um
brother man t-shirts coming really soon
to our Teespring it's what I'm saying
brother man brother man this is funny
yeah also I'm gonna debut this new
character spuds Buckley oh I like that
book I'm working on it I was told by our
lawyers that we're not allowed to use
brother man so I was thinking with
variation of it I don't want to get sued
we'll call it your man okay what do you
think
oh no no there just could be George
Floyd shirts
um I'm gonna start a new character
called flip flipperson oh I like flip
oh I'm gonna be I'm gonna be I'm gonna
be set I'm okay second cousin Pete there
you go second cousin Pete on Cameo and
I'm gonna go and I'm undercutting Norton
by five bucks on all the cameos [ __ ]
[ __ ] suckers I'm just gonna do that
remember that what's this aging comedian
character oh yeah Jim Norton
um and then I'm gonna make Dave Smith's
wife really uncomfortable make her quit
a show I'm really uncomfortable hearing
the story to be honest with you
oh [ __ ] flip flipperson is amazing super
simple
your [ __ ] [ __ ] up
undercut them go on Cameo undercut them
by five bucks first
hey Dave Smith I wanna [ __ ] your wife
um
[Music]
[Applause]
I mean I'm making fun of Jim no I know I
know and then and then and then [ __ ]
Jim Norton as chip was trying to hit on
Dave's now wife and then [ __ ] she
gave him the end of the mde sketch yeah
but the crippled kid and make him a
pickup artist and he's like yo [ __ ] you
need to suck my dick right [ __ ] now
and she's like uh
no thanks sardonic his head that's just
the end of the sketches the chick going
uh no thanks
so darn it so darnik is that's a good
point what about a black version of it
and you call them chimp chimpers
how funny Would it be though right if
Jim Jim was with Chelsea Peretti right
and then she goes on to be with Jordan
peel and he wins an Oscar how funny
would it be if he tried and failed to
hit on Dave Smith's wife and then she
becomes first
States
he gets elected president in a landslide
that [ __ ] guy's life sucks man
that would be so [ __ ] amazing
oh I will vote for Dave Smith just for
that reason how about that I'm making my
commitment that if Dave Smith runs for
president I will be voting for him I'm
gonna vote for Dave Smith just because
I'm I'm not voting for Trump I'm not
voting for him yeah I'm not doing it
oh
and I've marked my words [ __ ]
you want to blame me when the Democrats
win because I said that's not what
they're called demon Kratz I am gonna
vote [ __ ] libertarian this year old
traditional Studio why because the
Libertarians have been cozying up to us
lately they're kind of [ __ ] and I'm a
piece of [ __ ] clout Goblin with no soul
they're nice to us that's all it takes
here yeah that's nice to us
saying anymore and they're like we'll
build a studio wherever you want no he's
saying he's lot Mercy's lying he's
saying this radio company is saying
they'll build the studio wherever he
they're telling me that they think he's
such a [ __ ] lot woo Opie who
in Manhattan am I they're gonna build a
studio
in Manhattan
because so many people are craving Opie
and then I was thinking maybe get parts
because Matt would probably go for that
where we could turn something
some of the space over there into
something and I'm like
I'm like but here's the real issue I
don't know who I want to do it with
mm-hmm
it's not a matter of
you just have this [ __ ] stack of
applications and you just can't figure
out who with all the [ __ ] people
lining up to dance with you who you want
to go on the dance floor with it's the
fact that nobody likes you and nobody
wants to work with you anymore nobody
even wants to be associated with you
I'd rather be associated with Anthony
cumia
I am trying to
interdimensional lizard has a great idea
good name by the way Opie and Stuttering
John
oh I really like that so tell me tell me
what
the Trump these Trump pods [ __ ]
haters man the [ __ ] haters
the guys I wanted to do it with are no
longer Lin I guess if you had them you
have to call the podcast the other guys
right is he about to say All My Friends
Are Dead
well because you killed them I'm kidding
allegedly he didn't he didn't kill
anybody that I know of him look we saw
how Carl lives I said that I know of I
was gonna say Carl Carl killed Carl
Steve carlisi and that's the other
dilemma
so I kind of I kind of passed but we're
still like friendly and my imagined
agent are still
you know I still have one Wow Let's just
say they're pretty close to them
why do you have a manager
it's pretty gross another exciting
episode of babbling on the beach with ob
radio was the top comment
what happened to you man funny how he
talks about how legit the opportunity is
for uh for a while then says if I could
find a real opportunity I jump back in
if it's a legit company you wouldn't
know them they'd go to another school
it's a legit company you wouldn't know
them they go to another school
that's a funny line that's very very
they're real they're no they're real
they just go to a different School
but the problem with the company merch
is that it lives in Canada
with festivals with with fez's
girlfriend
I uh but there's nothing in the works
I'm not I can't oversell it you just did
Patsy just posted a shirt and Show links
thank you Patsy that's probably gonna be
respectable did he oh my God he's really
[ __ ] good nope
what do you think merch do we put it on
the Teespring immediately how fast
before
what what
happened
what a hideous t-shirt I love it though
I want it so bad I need to start in my
[ __ ] life that's really [ __ ] great
because they have my Opie
I know
I know it's a beautiful place because
they have my Opie is killing me
we couldn't make that shirt without his
picture and sell it on our Teespring he
doesn't own the copyright to the name
Opie because they're Green Acres
right
[Music]
I'm making it just black text right
by Grace it's so [ __ ] dumb I'm gonna
make it one I'll make it one thank you
Patsy thank you
you're a Jewish angel
oh
okay I think they're called demons
what
what happens
oh they are
[ __ ] that was funny that was very funny
God damn it
I think they're called demons
um
[ __ ] dick I'm stupid
that's [ __ ] funny